♪ Whoo ♪
♪ Like it or not ♪
♪ When I get going aint
no way I'm gonna stop ♪
♪ That's what I do ♪
♪ Like it or not ♪
♪ That's who I am ♪
♪ That's who I be ♪
♪ That's what I got ♪
♪ Uh huh uh huh ♪
- Greetings chums.
(intense music)
Check your sell by date ladies,
faux lesbian hasn't been taboo since 1994.
- Well I'm not great at
science, but I can point on this
if it's too weird for you.
- Weird why?
Oh, you mean because my
brother's being dissected
with a blade just like this one,
possibly at this very moment?
Don't worry, I'm fine.
(blade singing)
In fact, (squelching)
(gasping)
I'm amazing.
You catatonic bimbos didn't even vote.
So you stuttering sapheads are too dim
to exercise your own rights,
and you've got the combined
vocabulary of a baked potato.
Consider this your last
practice as River Vixens,
and your last week as
my social handmaidens.
You're fired on all fronts.
That's all, shoo, bitches!
(clacking footsteps)
(phone ringing)
- One more thing before
you go to the dance,
nana Blossom's ring, not in
jewelry box, not with Polly.
Where is it?
- It wasn't my fault it was Polly's.
She lunged at me trying to get
it, I didn't know what to do.
I panicked, I thought it
would be better for everyone,
if the ring were just,
gone, down the drain.
That way if Polly ever
said anything to anyone,
there'd be no proof.
Just her word against ours.
(intense music)
Did I do something wrong?
- No, quite right what you did.
(intense music)
- What is that smell?
- Gasoline.
It's the only way we can
truly start over, be purified.
(clicking)
(whooshing)
(crackling)
♪ Believer ♪
♪ Pain ♪
♪ My life my love my drive it came from ♪
♪ You break me down you build me up ♪
♪ Believer ♪
I'm telling everyone you ran back
into that towering inferno to save me,
not that hideous family
portrait that you love so much.
And that what happened at Thornhill,
was a terrible, tragic accident.
If you tell anyone the
truth about what happened
with the fire, I'll tell everyone
about what really happened
in the barn with daddy.
You were cruel to me mother, it was abuse.
Plain and simple.
So henceforth, if you breathe
it is because I give you air.
If you drink, it is because
I poured your cup myself.
And if you move, it is quietly
and with my blessing.
(gasping)
Things are going to be
different now mommy, better.
You'll see.
- Who is this?
- It's Cheryl, you welfare baby.
- Is something wrong?
- Not yet.
I just wanna make sure that
you know Archie and Betty
kissed in front of my house
right before Christmas,
and that it seemed pretty serious.
Like with tongue serious.
That's all, enjoy your
couples only weekend.
Kisses to all, bye now!
(clacking)
- Did you just tell Jughead
that Archie and Betty kissed?
- Yes, so what if I did?
- Did you at least have a reason?
- Oh, that's right, you're new here.
Hi, I'm Cheryl Blossom,
aka Cheryl Bombshell.
Which means, I need no
reasons, I simply am.
Feel free to tremble.
- I have a better idea,
why don't you tell me
what's bothering you,
because clearly, you're in a lot of pain.
- Get your sapphic
serpent hands off my body!
(clacking footsteps)
♪ You won't say you won't show ♪
- [Betty] Cheryl?
♪ How you feel ♪
(crashing)
- [Toni] Cheryl, are you in here?
- Toni?
- We came to rescue you.
- You did?
(gentle music)
♪ How can I keep myself away ♪
♪ When I'm falling hard for you ♪
♪ I've never known this kind of love ♪
♪ I can't help that I'm
falling hard for you ♪
♪ How do you ♪
- Cheryl, Toni, there are
a bunch of nuns coming,
we have to go, come on!
(creaking)
- Before we begin (thudding)
I've heard whisperings, that
some of you ensemble vultures,
don't think I'm fit to play or sing.
- No.
- The role of Carrie White.
So, to settle this matter
once and for all, maestro?
- Okay, Cheryl.
♪ That's not my name ♪
- Uh, Cheryl!
♪ I hear that word ♪
♪ Sounding so sweet ♪
♪ Thousands of voices
forever repeating Carrie ♪
♪ Carrie ♪
♪ I am the sound of distant thunder ♪
♪ That color of flame ♪
♪ I'm Carrie ♪
♪ I am a song of endless wonder ♪
♪ That no one will claim ♪
♪ But someday ♪
♪ Oh by someday ♪
♪ Someone will know my ♪
♪ Name ♪
(clapping)
- Wow, I think I speak
for everyone when I say,
that was undeniable, Cheryl.
(whip cracking)
(thudding)
- Ah!
(intense music)
(squeaking)
- You know who's blood this is mummy?
This is Jason's blood,
this is daddy's blood.
And the next blood to
be spilt, will be yours.
- Cheryl, dear God.
- You've been in cahoots
with daddy's twin.
You tried to kill nana Rose.
And then you shipped me
off to a ghoulish nunnery.
But your depraved gambits are finished.
If you so much as pluck one hair
from nana Rose's little head,
I'll end you.
I burned one house down,
I'll happily burn another.
- Nightmare child what
do you want from me?
- I wanna be emancipated.
I want Thistle House, all
to myself and my nana.
Start packing mummy.
You and uncle Claudius are pig people,
and should live amongst the pigs.
(rattling)
I also, feel it is my duty to say that,
like the furies of ancient Greece,
who ceaselessly pursue blood atonement
when a crime has been committed,
the Vixens and I vow that we will not rest
until those responsible for
the murder of our sister,
is rightly punished.
(gasping)
(clacking footsteps)
(clicking)
(thudding)
(gasping)
(clanking)
Ah!
(thudding)
(screaming)
(clacking)
(thudding)
(thudding footsteps)
(intense music)
(clacking footsteps)
(whooshing)
(rattling)
I suggest your run whilst you still can.
I only miss when I mean to.
(intense music)
(whooshing)
- Ah!
(gasping)
- Fine, you can have the jacket,
as long as you and the Ghoulies
stay out of the North side.
- Boy, you don't get to make demands.
(whirring)
Ah!
- Cheryl!
- I told you I was in the
mood for some hell raising.
- That's it, just kill 'em all.
- Cheryl aim your next arrow
right between Penny's eyes!
If you and your Ghoulies
take one more step,
she's gonna release that arrow.
(cracking)
Cheryl doesn't miss.
- Congratulations, you've just
made he North side fair game.
- Come on.
- Fire.
- He's not serious, is he?
- Fire Deadeye!
(rattling)
- Whoa!
(cracking)
- Don't test us, mumsy, we
know how to dominate too.
(clacking)
Get your hands off my girlfriend!
- Excuse me you can't be in here.
- What's going on?
- They're charlatans.
- What?
- Not another step!
Get up Toni, let's go.
- But my treatment.
- There's a chance Buddy's cries
that the sky is falling are true.
Look at those instruments of torture.
Now please, can we go?
(cracking)
- There's a door snuck Buddy in.
- Lead the way my Monte Christo.
(clanking) Uh!
(rattling)
- Stop those girls!
- Shane!
Take cover!
(yelling)
(whooshing)
- Ah!
(crashing)
(whooshing)
- Roni, here.
(swishing)
- Uh!
- Poisons charge!
(banging)
(yelling)
(intense music)
Welcome home Jay Jay.
(ominous music)
You're home now Jay Jay for good.
All is right in the
world, isn't it my love.
- Yep, everything's back to normal.